[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to the save by
the bell season two premiere event i am
your host aaron lynn rhodes i am so
excited to be here with you guys today
and on behalf of the entire cast and the
show we just wanted to set this up to
create some excitement and buzz around
the upcoming season of saved by the bell
we have some fun games we have the cash
joining us from both eras and we have
something very special at the end that
you do not want to miss so make sure you
hang around now it's time to see who we
have joining us from the og cast of
saved by the bell ladies and gentlemen
we have i'm elizabeth berkley lauren and
i play jesse spano uh mario lopez here
uh play ac slater hi i'm mark paul
gosseler and i play zach morris
hi i'm tiffany thiessen and i play kelly
morris
i'm mark voorhees and i play lisa turtle
and also joining us is scott evans who
is helping me host today and he is going
to be with the team cast so scott who do
we have over there
aaron what is up it is so good to be
here i'm scott evans and i'm going to be
handling or co-handling this event today
we're talking all things saved by the
bell and i'm pretty pumped about this
one but i don't want to wait any longer
let's go ahead and get these new faces
up on this screen let's introduce to you
the cast of saved by the bell the
peacock original i want to go by uh go
down the line one by one tell us who you
are and who you play
hey it's hoskidi velasquez and i played
daisy jimenez uh what's up my name is
mitchell hogue i play mac morris
i'm josie i play lexi
hi
i'm alicia pasquale pena and i play
aisha garcia uh my name is belmont
camelli i play jamie spano what's going
on y'all i am dexter darden and i play
devonta young how are y'all feeling is
is it good to see each other has it been
a while since you've seen each other
what's the deal you know it's it's quite
special that we're able to come back
together and and be able to sort of show
this connection again
uh 30 years later
it's so good to see everyone we miss our
big brother dexy we're so proud of him
as he shoots his movie and
it's been nice to sort of like reconnect
and have this little reunion for the
premiere
okay i got a game for you guys the main
question of this game is what would be
the first thing you would do if you were
principal for a day okay are you ready
[Music]
mario
what what are you implementing in this
school
four days a week bam three day weekends
every week i think if i was principal
for a day i would do like
maybe third period a salsa class or a
bachata class like just something to get
us moving and get all that energy off of
us from like sitting down and mine's
probably pretty simple um i recess all
day
i mean because
because recess is undeniably the best
part of school except for lunch
and um to account for that i would make
lunch outside
at recess
all day i think that uh as principal i'd
like to shorten the days um maybe start
at nine and uh nothing earlier and maybe
out by 2 30. uh also i'd like to
implement no more than one hour of
homework for all grade levels
if any at all because i think it's super
important for
kids to once they're done with school
just like we are with our jobs don't
take it home have fun with your family
or your friends uh so that you can go
back and and be excited about learning
the next day i i love yeah i love
everything you just said it would be a
game it's a life changer
lark it is time for you to let us know
what are you doing for the day if you're
the principal hosting a charity event
for the winter ball
if this whole acting thing doesn't work
out for you guys i think you should just
work for the school district
uh no thanks i feel like the fans
they are ready for season two it's
coming november 24th so i figured we'd
give them a little taste right of what's
to come let's check in with the season
two trailer for save by the bell the
peacock original
welcome back bayside
i can't wait to start junior year last
year you changed this place i got people
to care about important stuff not just
baseline nonsense hey dad think fast
this is gonna be awesome oh boy here we
go oh really
bayside is hosting the california school
spirit competition
it's the perfect venue for our second
kiss
and what a delicious sight to told me
you're not a part of this spencer hello
as many of you know bayside has a bitter
rivalry with valley our rivals just
destroyed our mascot
take me instead god make the switch you
coward let's go
okay people i have a big agenda so we
need to stop getting distracted yeah i
having a crush on someone is
embarrassing and distracting you're good
for me like broccoli
what oh yeah i know
you're looking at me jesse what's wrong
everybody knows i'm getting a divorce
fate is real you're working at the same
school as your first love you've been
through a lot my life sucks pretty bad
too 50 bucks says that my life sucks
more than yours you're on
that's a dollar
i see that money money money money
bayside hasn't won the spirit
competition for 200 years if we don't
learn from the past we are doomed to
repeat it that's why we have all these
reboots of teen shows from the 90s
get a new idea hollywood
last year i came to the school knowing
exactly who i was and now i have no idea
nobody knows who they are in high school
i call this meeting to order thank you
all for being here on a wednesday you
know the school everyone's day right on
hump day
yes
all right you guys while we are waiting
for the new season of the show i thought
it would be fun to throw it back so i've
gathered some old clips
from some old episodes some classics by
the way and viewers at home feel free to
comment in the chat and tell us what you
think because we are gonna hear from the
cast and hear what they have to say
one two three
[Music]
here's the message
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that is truly the best part of that
video is those literally fade in like
that's so classic late 80s 90s yes hey
was that an original song was that an
original song
yes that's pretty good that sounds like
the spice girls that was good i don't
remember it being that good
no we literally had to go record that oh
that was really good you guys i could i
was like oh that's a pretty good little
jam
okay if we made the show now
you know that peter engel would have
gotten us a record contract like a real
one
i mean because that was too good but the
only thing i have a question about is
how was that appropriate for 15 and 16
year olds to like oh the g strong
leotard
well but that was but remember elizabeth
that was very much the fashion it didn't
matter because you were wearing tights
you know what i mean like
i think it's actually hilarious that
that hasn't come back yet
i mean that's a
two and a half minute like legit video
that would be nowadays we'd it'd be put
up on youtube
and all the social uh channels and stuff
like that it's it's just crazy like you
guys shot like a legit music video that
was the one thing i i would say would
always save the day on set or
or on on
uh
studio time is that uh you get to call
your own shots i think you're right lark
we always had fun yeah and we we always
always arrive to the occasion to have
fun yeah okay let's move on to the next
clip hey you started it man making me
look like a jerk at the max well that's
what you are
what did you say
you heard me you get out of my face
and what if i don't punk
then i'll just have to make you punk
[Music]
can i ask you guys a question did anyone
do any sort of like
uh
choreography or was it just adrenaline
and go
no we did a little choreography we did
we did a little i do this you do that
and then you know we started to kind of
scrap him i mean we've talked about this
too we would never be able to get that
ever again in the current environment i
mean it's like we would have stunt
coordinators they'd be like
doubles and mats and and uh there's no
way that the they would ever allow us to
do that i mean that's like a really we
sold that punch you sold the hip toss i
mean we're on the ground you you throw
another punch i mean it was like those
were legit i mean that's like one of the
best fight scenes i've ever been a part
of yeah and i think you and i just
basically said this is what we're going
to do and we did it and you guys that
was it was concrete yeah that was the
sound stage this is not like you know
yeah
i remember actually watching that being
like literally in that scene watching it
slightly being nervous because i feel
like at that moment definitely that sort
of teen angst energy was still kind of
very much a part of us and i was a
little nervous i'm not gonna lie i was a
little nervous that someone was gonna
get hurt
okay you guys last clip for you
mirror mirror from the mall who's the
awesomest of them all if you say jesse
i'll bring you uh i pass next question
please
what harm can there be in eating these
if you only have 70 calories well the
dogs told me to be suspicious but i'm
tired of doing their shirts and dishes
you're a nice old lady i have no doubt
so i'll sample that
you know what i just realized
hamilton before hamilton oh
manuel miranda got his inspiration from
watching that he's a fan by the way
yo what the hell is that why did we do
that again why would we wrapping areas
that's actually a clip i have not seen
in a really long time i can't some of
these other ones i've seen but that one
i like i haven't seen that i can't
remember what anybody remember
why did we do that like why what was
that about
i i think it was just they they knew we
were all good with the musical kind of
thing and people were loving it and they
probably just did bennett tremor write
this one i'm trying to think he always
did
some fun special things like that i i
still like something something about
apples and that uh sometimes go i'll
sample that apple you're rapping about
it's just it's in me i can't get rid of
it
i would like to get rid of it
like tiffany so many people haven't seen
those clips in such a long time there
are a lot of details that i even forgot
but i wonder how much y'all remember so
scott what you have with this next
segment ah the energy is real and
speaking of classics let's check out
this clip from season one of the peacock
original featuring an iconic and a
timeless hangout spot check out this
oh look there's a gang
hey aisha and devonta what are you doing
here
well lexie's my buddy and she thought it
might be nice for us to get the chance
to know each other mm-hmm
and i thought it would be nice for her
to give me 50 bucks
yeah yeah
so devonta what tv do you watch have you
seen my reality show becoming lexi
cullen i am me it's about lexi's life
being transgender her journey is
self-discovery and the hot friends who
support her yeah if you watch it i'm in
episode 204 the big game at the end i
scored the losing touchdown i didn't
know you played football jamie really
cause he's literally been holding a
football all day huh
oh
it's i mean it's the gift that keeps on
giving when y'all do you watch back
episodes i imagine you guys watch back
you tweet you you you share the moments
that you love but when you see it in a
group like this together do you go back
to that first moment feel me
this is the first time we've ever had
the opportunity i feel like to really
watch it together outside of the pilot
we watched the pilot all together but
you know since covid um outside of the
pilot we haven't had the opportunity to
watch it together because we've all been
separated and you know so so seeing
clips like that from season one now that
we're all together it is it is very
different belmont i'm coming to you i'm
curious what it was like for you to walk
into
the max for the first time like what was
it like i mean it's iconic right
dude it's it's really surreal and that
was my first time my first day on the
universal lot was also my first day
seeing
the sets that had been prepared for us
ahead of time which
the scope of these sets is just
fascinating we spent a lot of time in
there and it has it has never lost on me
how special of a place that is no matter
we spend 10 hours in there uh on one day
and by the 10th hour i'm still
appreciative to be in that space it is a
very cool thing
josie that it is it is iconic
right from one generation and now to
another generation how does it feel to
be able to point at these
major moments this kind of cultural
shift also and know that you're a part
of it
it's so fun i mean the show was so
nostalgic to so many people so getting
to bring back all those elements that
people loved so much while also sort of
poking fun of that era is like very
exciting and and funny to do and our
show is so self-aware that's like one of
my favorite parts of it and just getting
to do that is is an amazing time and
yeah we love it we love making fun of
ourselves that's like
our thing
y'all do it well and it seems like it's
always
wrapped i mean it's it is like a
hardcore tease but it's always wrapped
in some love like it's like a brother or
sister cousin you know really close cuz
my first cousin though you know what i
mean all right so we're gonna play
another game this one's called never
have i ever
[Music]
and y'all have played this before i'm
sure but i also want to invite everybody
at home watching to play along in the
comments below
never have i ever tripped and fell in
front of the entire school
or gym class
okay we're gonna flip in one
two
three
everybody except for mitchell who didn't
go to school i didn't go to school
literally did not go to school y'all
forgot mitchell was never in class
never have i ever gone on a blind date
i was gonna say i feel like a blind date
these days like it doesn't really exist
like
you the first thing i do the first thing
i do is run up on somebody's instagram
okay let's see there's another here's
another one i think last one
um never have i ever forged a note from
my parents
wait what i love is that before alicia
even could write it down she was like
yeah me too i was like what y'all trying
to if i i can't lie to my mama now and
i'm an adult
scott what do you have for this next
segment
oh well aaron it's funny that you should
ask i've been wondering the very same
thing okay so next up we've got a little
segment that we're gonna call
easter egg okay so we're gonna show a
clip from the original series and you're
gonna tell me what you see that made it
all the way
into the peacock original you ready
[Music]
okay people settle down
i'm mr dewey hollis everyone summer
mine's stunk let's get
we're about started embark on an
exhilarating journey into the exciting
world of algebra
i'll wait till your heart stop pounding
this one's easy
okay
he has not left that job
since the original bayside and he has
the exact same lack of enthusiasm for
his profession and it is the funniest
thing any any time mr dewey's around i
feel better because
he just has this grave cynicism
and it's just so bayside that a teacher
like
doesn't really isn't interested in the
material doesn't care if the kids are
and his delivery his comedic timing and
the
lack of musicality in his delivery is
hilarious every single time i'm so
grateful that he's on the new show josie
it seems like you got something to say
i am
so dumb
i did not know that you know
josie
you just thought
you're fine guys i am in class i am
getting an education this is true i am
between takes i'm reading books
i'm talking about
i i did not know that he was in the
original show i'm sorry okay let's see
one more clip
[Applause]
how are you gonna like body slam a guy
and then not even celebrate but just
checking hair first like he's like let's
make sure this thing is in place
and then
the wig is always in place
also i'm pretty sure mario is wearing
the same leotard in season two that he
wore in the ocean like
i think that might be the same exact
outfit they just took that out of his
office i think this is the perfect time
to check the time and maybe uh share a
little special message for you guys take
a look
guess what
it's magic time
hey friends
i'm ed alonso otherwise known as max the
owner of the diner i just wanted to pop
in and say wow
what a show i mean from trivia to
principal for a day to that amazing
season two trailer and even more to come
if you stick around i'm talking fan q
and a's more games and maybe even some
season two sneak peeks i guess you'll
have to hang out with us for a while to
see for yourself
welcome back everyone we have a special
opportunity for a big saved by the bell
fan and she is going to ask a question
to the cast here with us is tanisha at
kiss that life away take it away girl hi
hi okay my question is how does it feel
stepping back into these characters 30
years later and did you think the show
would resonate
still with fans today
you know while we were making the show
we could never i mean in my opinion we
could never have foreseen that this many
years later we'd be
talking about it and and let alone doing
a reimagining of it um i mean when we
finished we thought that was it but
it's
we all know because we've all lived with
it every day of our lives
really receiving such beautiful
appreciation
on a daily basis i would say you know
walk wherever we would go and so i mean
of course that was really
heartwarming and as we've all worked on
other things the thing that just people
would always come back to is
you know their love for this show
whenever they might you know share their
appreciation for another job but
i think just because it's meant so much
to so many people for so long it's it's
such a part of their childhood
the innocence um
the goodness whatever
our kind of magical dynamics struck a
chord with people and they felt like we
were their friends
and so there was this deep connection
that really stays no matter what is
happening in someone's life it's been a
source of comfort and joy all this time
so
um it's kind of amazing to be able to
come together as grown-ups
and share that magic again
can i ask you one question um how old
were you when you first saw like your
first episode
i was three years old in 1989 when i
first saw it dang tanisha bye tanisha
bye tanisha
with your young ass
thank you so much everybody bye
bye we appreciate you
nice to meet you
we've seen some classic clips we've
heard from some fans but now let's see
if we can make things a little more
personal with some not so seen not so
popular footage
you know little latin kids like
maybe some type of motivation that hey
you know just because you're spanish or
whatever it doesn't mean because there's
not that many like when i was a little
kid i didn't remember ricky ricardo or
on lucy who else were you going to see
really so hopefully little kids oh maybe
i can do it because i mean especially
here in america there's a lot of latins
a lot of hispanics i'm glad that they're
trying to incorporate that into you know
different characters and maybe more will
evolve
[Applause]
[Laughter]
wow i love that wow
wow
no i love that you spoke about that you
know because it's something that we're
still having a conversation about in the
reimagining
with the new kids talking about
representation and
um i love that you
shared that back then thanks dad it it's
funny because you know in in looking
back
you don't really get to grasp how
special everything is at the moment i
think when you're that age it's fun to
do but how really like wow this is sort
of a
once-in-a-lifetime thing that could
never happen again right because when
you're young everything seems like
everything's gonna be great all the time
now when looking back these decades
later it's like what a special time so
to be able to revisit it again
makes it incredibly um both ironic and
and special yet again and uh it it's
neat that um
that all of us are here on the on the
zoom and um of course we're paying a
tribute to uh uh dustin in the very
first episode and i think it was done in
a tasteful uh way um
but the fact that we get to sort of
revisit
um both these characters and storylines
that i think could resonate with another
generation is is pretty cool
okay well jessie is um
very into world classes world peace
greenpeace very active and she's
straight a student very sensitive
yet she's very strong in that what she
wants and my character is lisa and she's
an okay student she's not just
do that well
she's into rural fashions and malls and
all that type of bit and
she likes to like hang out you know with
friends and stuff and she's just all
outgoing it's especially sweet to see
because
you know when we were filming the show
we didn't have
phones on set so we didn't get to
capture a lot of the behind the scenes
ourselves so it's really special to see
something out of character
and just speaking as ourselves from that
time just because we don't have the
record of it the way
maybe you know teenagers who are doing
shows right now have their instagram or
you know social media all of that we
didn't have that so there's that
innocence piece that i've mentioned that
you know in a certain way i wish we had
more record of that behind the scenes
but um so when we get to see it it's a
treat my name's tiffany amber thiessen
and i play kellie
kelly kapowski
um she's very outgoing um
cares about everybody very giving of
herself
i feel like for me that watching that i
think you could tell i was extremely
nervous because i think that was
probably one of the very first press
days that we ever did
um
for the show uh
you could tell how nervous i was
poor thing
all right you guys i know that it is
easy for true saved by the bell fans out
there to know some of your iconic lines
but now it's time to put it to the test
with you guys to see if you remember
some of these all right
okay
guys at home please play along in the
comments and elizabeth's going to be
very good at this
[Music]
i like school it's just too bad classes
get in the way
oh that's my marco it's definitely
that's exactly yeah yeah okay okay
you're right that was easy that was that
was aggressively easy okay how about
this one how about this one
have you ever noticed how all the m ms
taste exactly the same when they're in a
skittles bag jamie jamie yeah amy
yeah
zach i'm not a matador so take the bull
outside
i i think that's a jessie line that's
your line
sounds like a jesse line
anyone else out there
oh you're making me second guess
because it's not jessie it's definitely
a jesse one
should i go off
would i just say like screech
i'm gonna yeah this is to be different
maybe maybe it's not building
maybe ding ding it is building
ah
wow oh my god tiff i hate to disappoint
you tiff that was a deep cut right there
that was a deep cut
look who knows this show
time out what did that blonde fool just
say to me
that is i
yeah come on now easy all right next up
zach's idea of a good education is
sitting between a pretty girl and a
smart nerd
that's jessie
that's one thousand percent jessie
people expect plenty from me cool
schemes dope playlist this walk
mack mars cool walk mac yeah cool walk
mac
that's one of my favorite scenes he
walks he walks
next one she's my friend but not my best
friend actually i hardly even know her
[Music]
well the way you said it it sounds like
me but
i'm gonna go with kelly
i just put my kelly boys on okay let's
see this is a surprise for you guys i
don't know if you're ready for this but
uh in order
in order for this next game to happen
i've got to introduce another guest
let's see who it is
hey everybody it's john michael higgins
uh better known as principal
and i know you've all been having a lot
of fun talking about the exciting things
coming up on season two
they are exciting i know i was there
and of course all of the memorable
moments from the original series as well
lots of fun anyway
it's now time to
button it up shut up everybody because
this next game is all about detention
for example
which saved by the bell character would
most likely receive detention and don't
say me
you get the idea you get the hint anyway
have fun no talking
[Music]
so which character would get detention
for streaking across the football field
during the championship game who's one
attention for that
jamie jamie yeah yeah i think it's
probably jamie
who would get detention for fighting
over a crush who didn't even like them
zack
over
zach and slater who is going to what
character would be going to detention
for accidentally putting somebody in
their locker
devonte did that as his character well
like
one of them i would say i would say lexi
would accidentally put yeah in her
locker right because i think like
spencer would be spencer might be
holding a ring light or something and
then she'd just close it forgetting that
he's in there yeah yeah i mean so i'll
probably have to go like that
who's getting detention for panting mr
belding
that's zack
uh mr tuttle
it's another deep cut right there it
could also be it could also be principal
todd man um i i wouldn't
panting himself
okay so this is pretty exciting we've
got another opportunity for a major fan
of save by the bell to join us and
they've got a question to ask directly
so without further ado come on in
um
how did you feel when you first uh
walked into the set and found yourself
in that
iconic hallway that we we all had only
seen on television um
and let's start with um alicia
hi francisco um
it was you know surreal it felt
otherworldly you know it's it's always a
blessing to step into a job that you're
passionate about but then to know that i
grew up watching the show and watching
all those scenes go down in the hallway
and all of those different story lines
it it meant the world and then to have
the og cast members to come on it it
felt so special and you know to be a
little girl that was inspired by the
show and then have the opportunity to
continue the legacy in a way
was a blessing and then to look to my
side and be like oh my gosh i love the
people that i'm creating this with was
just super special
i think um just to kind of piggyback off
alicia we were we actually were able to
visit the set before like we started
filming and it was it wasn't fully done
but the whole time we were just like oh
my gosh the chairs and and the mac sign
and all this it was just like a very
surreal moment it was definitely i feel
for me a pinch me moment because
you see it on tv for all these years and
you hear about it and you see it in
photos and then to actually be standing
there it's kind of like what the you
know like this is really happening
i'm walking into the max and seeing the
red booths and you know the the burgers
and then also working with max the
magician how iconic he was
um you know because he's a part of the
he's a part of the max he's a part of
the show and he was a he was a real big
part of my childhood i always remember
like going to diners and being like is
this waiter going to give me a magic
trick or is he just going to put lemons
in my water and make it look like
lemonade so um
so
yeah so i just loved being having the
opportunity to shoot at the max and be a
cast member on the original save by the
i mean from being a fan of the original
save by the bell to being a cast member
on peacock saved by the bell that was
one thing that was really cool
thank you nice to meet you thank you so
much oh you guys today has been so much
fun
but sadly
we've reached the end of the road and it
is time to say goodbye but before we do
does anyone want to share any of their
favorite moments or express their
excitement for this upcoming season of
saved by the bell
you know i think they they did
they did a great job in the original um
or pardon me the the the launch blending
of the nostalgia with
now the new kids and touching on a lot
of
themes that resonate uh with uh uh with
young people today and at the end of the
day was it was pretty clever and funny i
think they are able to parlay that into
the next season and we get a lot more of
the original characters which hopefully
people will dig and they do a nice blend
so really happy with the way it turned
out and hopefully people tune in so
before you have a little turkey have a
little bell and slide into the holidays
that way
hi my name is tracy wigfield and i'm the
executive producer and showrunner of
saved by the bell on peacock to all our
fans new and old i just want to say a
great big thank you thank you for tuning
in last season and for all the love and
positivity about the show
and thank you for coming back for season
two we have a lot of fun and surprises
in store for you and i just can't wait
for you to check it out see you soon hey
everyone franco barrio here executive
producer and saved by the bell uh so
psyched that you guys are big fans of
this show i have been a pretty huge fan
for quite a while myself
um our cast our staff our writers and
crew are all so proud of this season and
we're so excited for you to get to see
season two was saved by the bell
um keep watching and uh hopefully
there'll be many more seasons um thank
you and see you soon
thank you guys so much it's been such a
pleasure thank you for watching
and uh enjoy the new season scott over
to you
honestly truly this has been such a
pleasure thank you guys so so much guys
thank you so much
truly but listen to officially shut this
thing down we've got one more clip from
season two it's an exclusive y'all
until next time
[Music]
previously on becoming lexi colin i am
me
i thought me single-handedly saving the
douglas kids was going to be the
craziest thing that happened in 2020.
little did i know
it wasn't
[Applause]
[Music]
so uh we got to shut everything down uh
schools stadiums the secret rich person
sex submarine in the hollywood reservoir
and out of an abundance of caution i
told linda to stay home cause i'm gonna
do my own sign language
but that didn't stop me from finding
love with the boy next door that filter
makes you look really pretty oh it's not
a filter it's just me
stop flirting this is geometry class and
to getting into a little drama no you're
gaslighting me dana
yeah suck on that but now life is
finally getting back to normal i can't
believe schools are reopening in a few
weeks is the line my producers told me
to say
mac
are you at kim kardashian's birthday
party aren't you scared jamie don't be
ridiculous yes 40 is very old for a
woman but i do not fear her
no
the virus oh i got vaccinated a long
time ago and my dad golf with either
johnson or johnson i forget which what
about you daisy are you excited for
school i am of course quarantine has put
into stark relief the inequities built
into ours
[Music]
me too
yo you're famous i know
oh um
i thought jamie looked really bad by the
way
you don't have to do that i'm over it it
was a year ago and not just a year a
quarantine year i'm just happy to be
back at school me too i can't wait to
start junior year in a real classroom at
a desk that isn't an ironing board girl
same i'm gonna pick up right where i
left off and that starts with becoming
class president again i got cheated out
of 50 of my term last year
but check this out
bam
the hard work we do now will pay
dividends in the future
for years to come dayz for president
is it bad
very but it doesn't matter before the
lockdown you united the entire school
pandemic or not nobody's gonna forget
that yeah
that's true i got people to care about
important stuff not just baseline
nonsense exactly you change this place
for the good
mark morris get me down from here well
even martin luther king couldn't get
everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you